Child actors don't just appear in kids'
movies. Plenty of actors in their teens
and younger have been in films with gruesome
imagery or disturbing subject matter. And even
if the filmmakers tried to shield them from
seeing too much, it surely had an effect.
The first thing 12-year-old Tim does in
"River's Edge" is throw his sister's doll
into a river. It's a mean-spirited act, but
it perfectly underscores the worldview of the
small-town teens in director Tim Hunter's 1986
film. Their alienation manifests in ways from
theft and drug use to cold-blooded killing.
Tim is the youngest of the film's characters
but also the most casually amoral. By the
end, Tim threatens to kill his own brother.
"You shouldn't have hit me."
"Don't be stupid, Tim."
Joshua John Miller, the son of playwright
and actor Jason Miller, was just 12 years
old when he replaced Corey Haim as Tim in "River's
Edge," and with only a handful of minor TV credits
to his name. But he's totally convincing
in carrying out Tim's list of cruelties,
which include stealing drug dealer Feck's gun and
later assaulting him with it. Miller would play
other kids on the edge — most notably
in "Near Dark" — before transitioning
to his current career as a writer and TV
producer. But none were as chilling as Tim.
The catalog of cruelties perpetrated by
Leena Klammer, a psychotic 33-year-old
posing as an adolescent girl, isn't the
most shocking element of 2009's "Orphan."
Leena kills multiple people, threatens other
children, and attempts to seduce her adoptive
father, but the really disturbing aspect
of these incidents is that actress Isabelle
Fuhrman was only 12 years old when the movie
was made. Yet Fuhrman was more than happy to
explore the gory aspects of her character.
As she told the Boston Herald in 2009,
"If America hates me, I've done my job."
Fuhrman doubled down on her astonishing
performance in "Orphan: First Kill," a
prequel released nine years after the previous
film. Though 25 at the time, Fuhrman gave another
chillingly believable turn as the 9-year-old Leena
with the help of body doubles, forced perspective,
and makeup special effects, but no CGI. Director
William Brent Bell told Showbiz Cheatsheet,
"Sometimes I think the visual effects component of
[digital effects] actually makes it look worse."
In "Thirteen," Tracy Freeland, played by Evan
Rachel Wood, is already close to emotional
ground zero when she enters the seventh grade. Her
divorced mom, Melanie, is a recovering alcoholic,
and her body image problems have led to
self-harming. When she meets popular girl Evie,
played by co-writer Nikki Reed, her need for
acceptance pushes her into rash acts, including
shoplifting, drug use, and casual sex, that spiral
into self-destructive behavior. Unfortunately,
Tracy has only her fraught relationship
with her mother as a support system.
Director Catherine Hardwicke and Reed, who
later collaborated on the "Twilight" franchise,
drew on Reed's own experiences when writing
"Thirteen." Though Reed later admitted that
she exaggerated some of her experiences in the
script, the anxiety and confusion of being a
teen girl rings true in much of the film. Wood
and Reed, who were 16 and 15, respectively,
at the time of filming, were strictly monitored
by Hardwicke, their own mothers, and a child
welfare worker during their most difficult
scenes to ensure their emotional well being.
In a 2015 interview with the late Anne
Heche and Heather Duffy for their podcast
"Better Together with Anne & Heather,"
actress Mariel Hemingway said audiences
would never see her Oscar-nominated
breakout role in Woody Allen's 1979
comedy "Manhattan" if the movie was
released in the current film market.
"I'm not condoning any behavior. I'm talking
about that movie. But that movie probably
couldn't come out today."
Why? For one, the film features a romantic
relationship between a 42-year-old writer, played
by Allen, and Hemingway's 17-year-old student.
While that scenario might have been offbeat
but acceptable in 1979, today, it reads as an
older man's creepy manipulation of a young girl.
Another reason is the accusations by
Allen's adoptive daughter, Dylan Farrow,
who alleged that he sexually abused
her when she was just 7 years old.
It's very difficult to keep that out of
mind while watching Allen canoodle with
the teenaged Hemingway. But even the
most forgiving viewer must note that
the cultural landscape has changed and that an
adult with a teenager under 18 is inappropriate.
Femme fatales have been a Hollywood
trope since the days of silent films,
but the stereotype takes an exploitative
turn when the dangerous woman in question
is a teenager. The 1992 movie "Poison Ivy"
aimed for a cross between film noir and "Fatal
Attraction" in its story of a sexually free
but homicidally inclined teen. The casting of
Drew Barrymore — then in a career rebound after
struggles with drug addiction — and name players
like Sara Gilbert and Tom Skerritt attempted
to lend respectability to the sleazy plot.
Barrymore, then 17, isn't particularly convincing
at depicting Ivy, a deranged teen so taken with
Gilbert's normal life that she's willing to
seduce her father and kill her mother. The
character is aware of her desirability but
unable to use it for anything except base
interests. Barrymore gamely handles the story's
more prurient aspects, which include making out
with the 17-year-old Gilbert and 60-year-old
Skerritt and pushing Cheryl Ladd off a balcony.
The 1998 film adaptation of Stephen King's novella
"Apt Pupil" differs from its source material,
but the film retains its disturbing portrait
of evil's corrupting influence. The late Brad
Renfro stars as Todd, a teenager who
discovers that his elderly neighbor,
Kurt Dussander, played by Ian McKellen, is a
former Nazi. The teen blackmails Dussander into
telling grisly stories from concentration
camps. Their relationship warps both men
in dangerous ways — Todd blackmails his guidance
counselor, while Kurt starts killing transients.
Though some of the grislier elements of
King's story are toned down for the movie,
many are featured in Brandon Boyce's script. For
Renfro, who was 17 years old during production,
that meant participating in scenes where
Todd helped kill a homeless man and a
fantasy sequence in which he envisions his
classmates as concentration camp prisoners,
which prompted a lawsuit against director
Bryan Singer for infliction of emotional
distress and other charges. Todd's corrupted
innocence was familiar to Renfro throughout his
acting career in films including "The Client"
and, tragically, in his own life off-camera,
which ended with his 2008 death from
a drug overdose at the age of 25.
Petr Kotlar was just 11 years old when he
was cast in Czech director Vaclav Marhoul's
2019 adaptation of Jerzy Kosinski's novel "The
Painted Bird." He couldn't have picked a more
harrowing story for his debut; the movie follows
a mostly silent boy wandering through a surreal
hellscape in Eastern Europe during the early days
of World War II. The boy is brutalized — beaten,
sexually assaulted, and tortured —
and witnesses horrific behavior by
every adult he meets. Kotlar had never
acted on film before but holds his own
in scenes opposite Stellan Skarsgaard,
Harvey Keitel, and the late Julian Sands.
In an interview with The Guardian, Marhoul
said he shielded Kotlar from the most
traumatizing scenes by capturing his reactions
separately from the action. He also relied on
Kotlar's family and a full-time assistant to
provide him with emotional support when it was
needed. Despite the protection, the experience
seems to have impacted Kotlar. Marhoul said,
"After, he told me he
doesn't want to be an actor."
Alicia Silverstone made her big screen
debut in "The Crush," a supremely icky
thriller that cast the 17-year-old actress as
a 14-year-old lethal Lolita with designs on
a 28-year-old journalist played by Cary Elwes.
The film, directed by TV vet Alan Shapiro, plays
on familiar sexist tropes about teenage girls
and the clueless adult men who fall for them.
"I'll always be your friend,
no matter what. OK? OK."
"Like that night up at the
lighthouse when we kissed?"
Elwes' character steps into every snare laid by
Silverstone and then experiences
a moment of crisis about her age,
which is supposed to generate sympathy when she
unleashes a torrent of psychotic behavior on him.
"The Crush" portrays Silverstone as a
contemptible object while also fetishizing
her sexuality. As the film's villain, she's given
all sorts of outlandish schemes to carry out:
she nearly kills Elwes' new girlfriend and pins a
charge of sexual assault on him. At the same time,
the film also affirms that it's okay to enjoy
the camera ogling a supposed 14-year-old at
every turn. The Washington Post's review summed up
the film's have-it-both-ways approach by noting,
"There's something scuzzy
about the whole exercise."
Guillermo del Toro is a passionate advocate of
writer-director Issa Lopez's 2017 Mexican film
"Tigers Are Not Afraid," which is both
a haunting supernatural thriller and a
melancholy look at the impact of drug violence.
But as with del Toro's films like "The Devil's
Backbone" and "Pan's Labyrinth," "Tigers
Are Not Afraid" is also about the terrors
and traumas of childhood and how some children
learn to survive them while others do not.
To deliver that gut punch, Lopez worked
with an extraordinary group of young
actors and put them through an emotional
workout, though it was carefully guided.
The young actors in "Tigers Are Not Afraid"
play residents of an unnamed Mexican city
ravaged by drug lords. The children lose
virtually everything — parents, homes,
even mementos — and death is around them
at all times. Bodies lie in the streets,
adults and children are killed violently in front
of them, and children are forced to fight and even
kill in return. Ghosts are also a constant
presence, urging revenge for their deaths.
Director Scott Derrickson's thriller "The Black
Phone" is so briskly paced that viewers might
almost miss the storyline's truly horrible
elements. An adaptation of a short story by
Joe Hill, the film focuses on Finney,
played by Mason Thames, a teenager who
has been abducted by a child murderer known as
The Grabber. Though terrified, Finney begins to
receive visions and messages from The Grabber's
deceased victims and formulates an escape plan.
Finney's communication with the victims
is so otherworldly that it's almost easy
to forget these kids have died in particularly
tragic ways. They were stolen off the streets
of their hometowns and tormented by a sadistic
masked killer who eventually took their lives
in a way that undoubtedly "really hurt," as
The Grabber puts it. The unendurable sadness
of Finney's fate and their deaths is felt
in the emotional line readings by Thames,
who was 14 when the film was released
in 2021, and his young cast mates.
In 2015's "Goodnight Mommy," a woman
returns to her isolated home after surgery,
where her twin sons greet her. At least, they
believe she's their mother, but her angry,
often violent reactions to them cause the
boys to suspect otherwise. They hold her
captive in increasingly cruel ways to
extract a confession from her, but what
they eventually discover is far more complicated
and chilling than a simple impostor situation.
Adding considerably to the creepiness of this
Austrian film is that two young boys play the
twins. Elias and Lukas Schwarz, who, according
to various sources, were 12 while filming,
carry out many unsettling acts. They raise
huge cockroaches and look after a dead cat,
and eventually tie down and seal their
alleged mother's mouth shut to prevent
her from screaming for help. When she refuses to
change her story, the boys glue her to the floor
and set the house ablaze. By that point, it's
far too late for anyone to change their story.
Michael Haneke's 1997 film "Funny Games" is a
polarizing experience. You're either wowed by
the movie's deliberate manipulation to produce
maximum horror or completely disgusted by its
catalog of sadism. The brutality two strangers
bring upon an Austrian family is painful to watch,
and the torment seems to have no
point beyond amusing the culprits.
The family's son, Schorshie, suffers some of
the worst abuse. Not only does he witness his
parents' torture, but he also stumbles upon the
corpse of his neighbors' daughter in an attempt
to flee. The boy, played German actor Stefan
Clapczynski, who was only 11 at the time of
filming, is also featured in one of the film's
most infamous scenes, when he's mercilessly
shot by one of the strangers. The on-screen
death of a child is upsetting for audiences,
but when accompanied by so much other awful
behavior, it's an almost unbearable experience.